hi everyone this is Jerry this is a game
between George Riley we in Akiba
Rubinstein this is known as Rubenstein's
immortal he was regarded as one of the
finest endgame players to ever play the
game however in this particular instance
we don't get to see any of that end game
play instead it's just an opening
advantage obtained by black and then
that advantage was put to very good use
come middle gameplay so you have to turn
the clocks back for this one I just
played in 1907 where George with white
opened with d4 Akiba responds d5 at f3
d6 and III so these are two very tame
looking moves both sides are seemingly
content with having to fee and Ketel
their bishops 2 B 2 and B 7 C 5 and C 4
so we have both sides striking at one
another Center and we have a tirage
defense when we have these two pawns
here in the center where there's you
know just all this tension going on
between the D and C pawns what can often
occur as one side or the other will be
saddled with the and isolated Queen pond
for example if takes in the following
ways white would have an isolated Queen
pond or if instead of taking on d4 we
had black play Knight f6 we could have
white imposing an isolated queen pawn on
black d5 pawn is the isolated pawn so in
this game neither that occurs but it's
worth taking note of it so instead we
have knight c6 Knight c3 and Knight f6
so classical development for the Knights
and in fact we have a symmetrical tirage
defense both sides have made identical
moves this position that you're looking
at has simply come about by a different
move order so pawn takes Bishop takes a
three looks to support B for a six B for
Bishop back and now Bishop to b2 one
quick thing to note is that if you're
playing the white side here and you're
the type of player who maybe gets overly
excited with advancing your pawns just
to create these one move threats such as
a move like c5 there's a serious
drawback
such a move the bishop could simply just
be tucked back here and something
serious has just occurred
more specifically the pawn structures we
have a three-on-two on the Queen side
and a five-on-four on the Kings side or
you could look at it as a one on two in
the center in favor of black if you're
going to make these type of pawn advant
advantage you had better be prepared to
cope with your opponent pushing their
majority forward so blacks majority lies
in the center so you should be well
equipped to meet these sort of advances
you know this pawn may be coming to e5
and then maybe to e4 and once it's there
notice how the knight would be kicked
are you prepared to deal with that sort
of thing because you're probably going
to want to Castle kingside right and if
your Knights not here there might be the
bishop coming down to take on h2 and
then you know after the King takes we
have Knight g4 checking the King the
Queen comes out to h4 I know I just went
off and this is like very John Madden
like but the point I'm trying to get to
is don't make these premature type of
pawn advances unless you're in a
position to cope with potential pawn
storms that could come about we have a
two-on-one in the center are you going
to be able to meet this sort of pond
advance potentially just some food for
thought that doesn't occur instead
Bishop b2 black castles so we're just
getting our minor pieces out get castle
and move the Queen up connect the rooks
etc Queen d2 Queen e7 so black is
offering a pond with this last move you
know well actually white in this
position couldn't go ahead and win upon
in the following way this would lose
tactically we're not going to want to do
this as white so the Queen's going to be
lost and splat black is checking the
white King so after this right here
after Queen d2 Queen e7 now I could go
ahead and take like this so white could
actually win upon in this position
however white doesn't go for this
because I guess
white didn't like that they would be
behind the development so white would
still need to moves before their castled
and in the meantime there's already this
threat in the air discovered attack on
the Queen the bishop is ready to come
out hit the Queen rook on the other open
file so white simply doesn't go for it
but something that Kiba had to give
consideration to instead we have Bishop
d3 takes takes b5 hits the bishop and
I'll rip to d8 so placing the rook
opposite the Queen we don't want to be
in that sort of position as white so
let's get the Queen off that file
Queenie tuba should be seven in white
castles typically I would spend some
more time on the opening in in my videos
however there's a good reason why I
chose to kind of just kind of speed
through the opening phase like this and
it's because if you take a good look at
this position right here what you'll
notice is that it's symmetrical except
for this rook here if this rook we're
still on it's on this f8 square we have
every piece symmetrical with one another
it's blacks move in this position and
black already has a rook ideally placed
on one of the open files so how did this
come about we know in chess white moves
first in the game so how is it the case
that black is now the side that has a
lead in development that lies in some
inaccuracies that was played on the
white side I know it's very easy to
simply get caught up in all these flashy
type of moves in chess you know that the
fireworks and stuff like that but how is
it you know how is that all possible
well it comes from a superior position
Fischer was quoted as saying tactics
flow from a superior position well
that's exactly what we have in this sort
of position going on black is able to
put this to very good use so if we just
hit the rewind button we'll recognize
these little inaccuracies that I
purposely skipped over initially so how
is it the case that this position
evolved to a position where black is
leading and developing
so up to this point right here this move
after night here this move by white is
an inaccuracy to take on c5 prior to
this bishop moving is an inaccuracy or
at least a better move would be
something like a3 preparing to maybe
respond you know after black maybe moves
the Bishop to e7 only now take and after
the bishop recaptures you'll notice that
the bishop had to take a pit stop on e7
and only then come to c5 the bishop
would then have to move twice so that's
a way that white could have improved so
we didn't see that but that's just a
quick thing to note white our black bear
in mind could also be stubborn and not
move this bishop just yet and do a
similar move like a6
you know and then you know if this
occurs we have something similar going
on but that didn't occur again just a
better move with to simply which is
simply B not to take on c5 right away
but instead play a3 but black is able to
just go from point A to point B so to
speak from f8 to c5 in one shot so a3 a
6 + b4 chases the bishop back to d6 this
should be 7 so where's the other
inaccuracy it lies in this move right
here Queen d2 and notice that eventually
what ended up occurring the Queen went
to e7 and notice when the bishop came to
d3 only now does black take on c4 so
black is making this bishop stop here
first and only then go to the c-4 square
so black is making white spend 2 moves
before it ends up recapturing on the c-4
square so that's another time-saver the
bishop is chased Bishop goes back and
after rook d8 developing move right we
want to get the rooks on the open files
and now all of a sudden this Queen has
to move for a second time this was her
little journey D to e to this bishops
journey was to d3 c4 and then well it
goes back to d3 so these are the little
details
that led up to this current position
right here where black is now the side
that has a lead in development those are
the little inaccuracies which really
make all the world will really make a
world of difference so what we do see
next is black simply uncovering this
bishop strength so we have Knight to e5
immediately putting pressure on this
night it's very tempting to maybe just
want to play this rook here but then
maybe it's the white knight that can
come here and unleash this bishop so
black wants to make this move first and
in doing so you're now preventing this
Knight from making use of that sort of
move so Knight to e5 was played Knight
takes bishop takes and now f4 so this
move is played with the intention of
following up with this efore advance you
know if you're not going to follow up
with this sort of advance efore you know
after after f4 like this the bishop just
goes back here if you're not going to
follow up like this then this would just
be a weakness this would just be a
backward pun and a liability that which
could potentially be targeted by the
bishop so that's exactly what occurs
after f4 the bishop goes back to c7 you
don't want to go here this rook would
you just get it in the way of your rook
so ideally you're going to want your
bishops off of the open files so the
bishops ideal square is going to be here
and that's very sensible you know as a
direct result of this f4 move what
Square has been weakened III so it makes
sense to maybe want to put pressure on
this III point the additional benefit is
that actually just coming to this square
would then you know you'd be placing it
opposite the king as well so II for rook
to c8 the rooks are placed on the only
open files and we have white simply
advancing e5 so attacking Knight and
black ignores that for the moment simply
gives a check and now King to h1 so just
taking a quick look at this position
right here
what we have going on the rooks are on
the open files these are just like to to
guns going on the DNC files and the
these are to just you know these bishops
are just knifing their way down at the
White King side so these these are just
beautiful positions for these bishops
and rooks so what to do about this
threat against the knight well let's
just move it you know we have a
situation here where the Queen is simply
tied down to the defense of the bishop
so if Queen takes simply rook takes not
a big deal black is definitely the side
who's doing better open position we have
this x-factor bishop the unopposed
bishop LightSquared bishop so white
won't be doing that and instead if we
have this desperado taking on h7 and
only then taking here well more bad news
for white the rook comes to the seventh
rank hits here and here so that's why
we're not seeing something like that
occurring instead after Knight G for
what we do see is Bishop to e5 just
trying to negate this bishop strength
he's bearing down against the white King
so it makes sense to just want to
exchange this guy off for sure and now
simply Queen to h4 and this is the move
that was played with some great
calculation and we really finish up very
shortly from here so Queen h4 most
directly it's threatening a mate in one
so how to defend g3 was played so now
the Queen is going to defend that h2
square and now a very deadly sacrifice
rook takes Knight so what's going on
here the Queen could simply be taken and
that's exactly what occurs in this game
but just looking at a quick what if what
if Bishop takes we would simply have
rook takes pawn and the threat of simply
taking on h2 with the night followed by
rook to h3 winning the Queen would be
just game over from there you know
really what is there to do from such a
position for example if you know Bishop
here Knight takes the threat of just
moving the knight with the discovered
check is lethal so after Queen takes
simply rook here it's just downhill
white we don't see that instead white
simply goes for accepting the sacrifice
so pawn takes Queen so what's the
follow-up what do we do well we get one
of the last pieces involved although
this rook is already positioned on the D
file we want to have it function
laterally we have an instance here where
this rook on a8 played to c8 and in
doing so it's functioning in one
direction however once it played to this
c3 square once it played to the c3
square we see that it's now a
multi-purpose piece functioning in both
directions so that's exactly what occurs
with this next move we have this rook
now becoming a multi-purpose piece not
just functioning along this file but now
this rank so what to do from this
position the Queen is simply hit by the
rook if Queen takes like this we're just
going to simply run into Bishop check
and what to do from here I mean you
block with the rook we're just going to
take like this there's a nasty
discovered check coming about after this
rook moves that would just be game over
instead what we did see is simply Queen
takes rook Bishop takes Bishop check the
Queen has to block and now black simply
puts the final touches on the white side
by playing this spectacular rook to h3
move what to do exactly the queen is
pinned and essentially powerless so if
Queen takes Bishop we just simply have
rook takes a ch2 and that's Met or
that's me the bishop is covering that G
1 square what else is the is there to do
from such a position well
computer wise if White was playing the
computer side these would be the only
moves to prolong checkmate from this
sort of position there's no way to
prevent rook takes h2 on the very next
move which would deliver checkmate so
that's all for this video I hope you got
something out of it take care bye